hi guys this is Luxur from simply done
welcome to this tutorial on Java strings
this is a part of a Java tutorial series
where we will be covering everything you
need to know to master Java let us look
at what we will cover today first we'll
see what strings are in Java then how to
create define and declare strings then
operations that can be done on strings
some inbuilt methods in string class and
finally we'll do two main programs to
understand the working of Java strings
so let's get started let's see what
strings are and how we can use strings
in Java Java strings are objects that
contains groups of characters like
arrays strings are immutable as well
immutable means one string is created
they cannot be changed or manipulated if
we use a string hello they are stored in
a memory location like this 0 1 2 3 4
are the addresses of the locations where
each character of the string is stored
now let's move on to creating strings
there are two methods of creating string
string literal method and using new
operator this is the syntax of string on
the screen first string type then
variable name is equal to sequence of
characters in double quotes this is
called as string literal method for new
operator method we use new operator and
value of string is given in the brackets
now let's see a simple program to
understand the use of strings with Java
code let's create a new project file new
project next tick the box next I'm going
to leave it as strings and for the base
package I'm going to name it as string
as well because all the programs I'm
going to do in this package for strings
we have our main program right here the
main class now before importing the
strings we need to import some
pre-processing directives so for this
for this I am gonna import Java dot I
input output dot star star means
everything inside the directive and I'm
going to import Java dot length
dot star this means I can do all the
operations that is needed for Strings so
there are two ways to declare string
this is the first one string s is equal
to simply learn now we have a string s
and it contains the value simply learn
now I'm gonna print this system dot out
dot println plus s R I'm gonna name it
as string I'll print string first is
equal to and then I'm gonna print this
so double quotes string is equal to and
plus s so let's run this program and
there we go we have string is equal to
simply learn so it took the value of s
and printed that so let's see the next
type of string how we can declare the
string the STR is equal to new string
simply learn so this is the second
method how we can declare string or
assign the values to string so to print
it I am going to use string two is equal
to and then plus STR so let's execute
this as well and as you can see we have
string two is equal to simply learn as
well so this means both the methods are
to declare strings or to assign values
to the strings so you can use any of
them I prefer using first so it's easy
that's why you don't need to write new n
string so let's move on to the new topic
classes in strings we all know that
strings are immutable now what if we
want to change something inside the
string then we use these methods to
manipulate strings in Java first one is
string builder the string builder in
Java represents a mutable sequence of
characters it is an alternative to
string class as it creates a mutable
sequence of characters
next is string buffer string represents
fixed length immutable characters of
sequences while string buffer represents
global and writable character sequences
it will automatically grow to make room
for additions like appending inserting
and deleting next we have string
tokenizer
a string tokenizer object internally
meant
a current position within the string to
be tokenized some operations advance
this current position past the
characters processed string tokenizer
class in java is used to break a string
into tokens her token is returned by
taking a substring of the string that
was used to create the string tokenizer
object now let's say different methods
for functions that can be done on
strings in java we have lot of methods
or functions in strings these are few of
the methods that are used by programmers
frequently and we will be using in this
series of a java tutorial first one we
have int length that returns length of
the string second we have string
substring int begin index that returns
the substring for a given begin index
next we have boolean is empty then
checks if the string is empty or not
next we have string concat string STR
that concatenates the specified string
next we have string split string rejects
returns a split string matching rejects
next we have int index off int CH that
returns a split string matching rejects
next we have string to lowercase and
string to uppercase these are mostly
used when we want to convert a string
into uppercase or into a lowercase next
we have string trim that removes
beginning and ending spaces of the
string if we have any beginning or end
spaces that may not be required for a
string then we use this next we have
static string value of int value this
method converts given type of into
string it is an overloaded method and
lastly we have string replace character
old and character new it replaces all
the occurrences of the specified
character value next let's have a look
at a program where we are going to
reverse a string and compare to string
this is going to be an interesting
program and you will be able to
understand string a lot better so let's
get started so first we will see how to
compare two strings and then we will see
how to reverse a string so let's create
a new project file new project let's
click on next tick the box next
rename it as compare and reverse because
I'm going to do both the programs in the
same program and we have our main
function here to use some classes or to
use some methods we need to import some
of the strings from Java so I'm going to
import strings dot compare dot string
compare
so let's write our code here so I'm
gonna use four strings first string s1
is equal to then I'm going to use new
string and am inside it I am going to
name the string s simply learn
as capital and for the next string
string s2 is equal to new strain
let's give it as practice for the third
string as three new string
let's give it as study and for the first
fourth string we are going to match in
the third string to show all the outputs
that's possible study now we are going
to display some output using the
function equals so what equals does is
it it compare two strings so first I'm
gonna use it make it as user-friendly by
writing comparing string one and then
comparing string two and then semicolon
so that everything will be separated you
can easily find out what the result will
be and then this is the main part s when
dot equals and in the bracket s two
because we are comparing s 1 and s 2 so
s 1 dot equals s 2 this function
automatically checks whether s 1 is
equal to s 2 now same thing we are going
to do with string s 3 and string s 4
again this user friendly as 3 and s 3
dot equals s 4 we know that s 1 is not
equal to s 2 but s 3 is definitely equal
to s 4 so let's try it with one more
sentence so that we can compare one more
string so I am going to compare s 1 and
s 4 so I will copy pasted it and instead
of s 3 and write s 1 and same I will do
with s 1 dot equals s 4 so let's run
this program before running we have a
error here so I'm going to delete that
input because we have not used it so now
let's run the program and yes we have a
result comparing simply learn and
practice is false
that's definitely false study and study
both strings are matching so it's true
and simply learn and study they don't
match that's why it's false so let's get
started with a second program that's
reversing a string so I'm going to
delete everything from here and I'm
gonna write same code here only so first
I need to assign a variable of string
string input equals and limit as simply
learn and this is the main part guys we
use string builder because the string is
immutable and as we discussed earlier
string builder allows us to do
manipulation so I'll use one more
variable input 1 and new string builder
so in input 1 we can do any manipulation
that we require so first I'm going to do
input 1 dot dot append so that I can do
operations that I want on it either
reversing or deleting or concat so I'll
take up end of input
and lastly input 1 is equal to input 1
dot reverse this function reverse the
string that is there in input 1 now to
print the value of the river string the
reverse string is and then input 1 so
here's the catch guys we have to use
string builder so that we can do
manipulation since inside the string if
you don't use string builder then we
will get an error that unable to
manipulate the string or unable to
reverse the string so string builder is
the main thing here so that we can do
all the operations that we want either
reversing or concat or deleting anything
from the string or building an element
or adding anything to the string so all
that happens because of string build up
so now let's run this program
and there we go we have a result the
reverse string is the reverse of simply
learn now let's try it with something
that is palindrome so we have a language
Malayalam if we reverse this will get
Malayalam so this is kind of palindrome
string and see the result
the reverse ting is also Malayalam so
this is how you reverse a string so this
brings us to the end of this video we
learnt about strings the functions for
strings and the methods we use in
strings and lastly we learn how to
compare two strings and how to reverse
two strings I hope you like this video
thank you for watching stay tuned for
more from simply learn hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learning YouTube channel and click here
to watch similar videos turner up and
get certified click here